bienvenue dans votre émission politique
que j'ai le plaisir et l'honneur de
présenter avec Jean-Marc parti
quatrième relais de notre panorama de
2023 sous les perspectives qui nous
attendent ce soir nous allons parler de
l'Europa Martinique de la Martinique
dans l'Europe avec notre invité le
député européen max Orville monsieur
l'euro et Le Rheu député bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation c'est
moi qui vous remercie et je suis content
de d'échanger avec vous ce soir pour
éclairer nos compatriotes
d'ailleurs entrer dans le vif du sujet
Jean-Marc avec ce point sur l'actualité
brûlante oui le gouvernement français
maxorville a entamé une réforme du
régime des retraites l'un des arguments
qu'il avance c'est la nécessaire
égalisation du régime français avec ceux
qui se passe dans l'ensemble de la
moyenne des pays de l'Union européenne
est-ce un progrès selon vous cette
réforme
laquelle la vraie question c'est de
savoir selon moi est-ce que cette
réforme est nécessaire
de mon point de vue c'est pas forcément
accepté par tous je crois que oui il
faut que savoir qu'il y a des déficits
qui s'accumulent d'année en année donc
il faut faire cette réforme maintenant
est-ce que on peut je suis forcément de
la majorité présidentielle partenaire
tout le monde le sait cependant il n'y a
des nuances pour ma part j'avais
toujours prôné comme le président du
MoDem François Bayrou le disait depuis
25 ans moi j'optais plutôt j'avais une
préférence pour le système à points qui
tenait compte davantage de la question
de la pénibilité et qui était à mon avis
beaucoup plus adapté pour pouvoir
avancer cependant
comme tout le monde le gouvernement peut
avoir un avis différent du mien donc les
débats vont s'engager très bientôt et
j'espère que nous arriverons tous à
trouver un consensus acceptable
préparer difficile
nous allons découvrir maintenant un
petit peu qui se cache derrière le
député européen Jean-Marc parti vous a
concocté une petite biographie
que vous êtes âgé de 60 ans vous avez
été instituteur puis directeur d'école
de profession sur le plan politique vous
êtes engagé au modèle mais de François
bayrout vous êtes le président de la
fédération de Martinique vous avez été
conseillé municipal à 15 pilote votre
ville d'origine si je puis dire ainsi
que helcher un peu plus tard et vous
étiez placé en 24e position sur la liste
des produits par Nathalie Loiseau au nom
de la majorité présidentielle aux
élections européennes de mai 2019 et
puis à la faveur d'une nouvelle
désistement il y a un peu moins d'un an
puisque le députés européens est devenu
manque du gouvernement vous êtes enfin
au sein du Parlement européen à
Strasbourg et à Bruxelles vous
expliquerez comment vous faites pour vos
déplacements et j'ajouterai que vous
faites partie
[Musique]
des propositions des suggestions que
fait la commission infinie donc mon
travail consiste dans un premier temps
donc à faire cette loi à rendre une
Europe beaucoup plus sociale je m'occupe
de salaire minimum on a voté un certain
nombre de
directives visant à être beaucoup plus
proche du citoyen européen en termes de
réduction de la pauvreté etc maintenant
plus précisément pour répondre à votre
question
ultra précise un ultramarin et bien
effectivement sur 705 euros député nous
sommes 7 euros députés issus des régions
ultra périphériques c'est à dire
globalement 1% 1% c'est tout petit ça
peut même ne pas compter mais ça nous
appelle à une grande vigilance sur tous
les textes qui seront votés au Parlement
et qui peuvent venir en contradiction de
l'intérêt des régions ultra
périphériques voire même menacé
l'économie
le territoire c'est ainsi que en août
dernier en juillet dernier nous avons
voté une dérogation pour un territoire
proche c'est celui de la Guyane qui se
voyait menacer dans son autonomie
énergétique donc on demandait à la
Guyane n'utilisez plus les énergies
fossiles n'utilisez plus la biomasse
primaire la biomasse primaire c'est ce
qui permet de produire de l'électricité
et également
cette activité était une activité qui
emploie qui était le deuxième employeur
du privé non quand même au sein du
Parlement vous menez quand même une
activité de lobbying en tout cas pour
protéger certains intérêts à des régions
ultra périphériques et même des Antilles
on va parler des Antilles un petit peu
le bassin Atlantique même s'il n'y en a
plus hein
j'ai envie de dire c'est toutes les
rupes françaises donc vous voyez un
petit peu jusqu'où ça va et l'attention
et la vigilance que nous devons avoir
pour par exemple ne plus avoir
d'inadaptation aux normes je prends
toujours le fameux un exemple de la
Guyane ou lors d'une visite en 2012 en
2011 en Guyane on visite une une
entreprise qui fait du poisson fumé et
qui nous raconte une énorme idée il est
obligé le chef d'entreprise d'importer
du bois de hêtre pour fumer ses poissons
alors qu'on a l'Amazonie ça c'est ce que
j'appelle l'inadaptation des normes
absolues sur lesquelles il faut veiller
c'est la même chose en ce qui concerne
la pêche mais on aura l'occasion de
parler merci pour ces précisé un max et
en ville mais vous savez vous l'avez
constaté que l'Europe reste encore
relativement méconnu
plus exactement l'Union européenne et
ses différentes institutions à la
partenaire avec le continent européen
globalement parlant et à ce sujet nous
avons posé une question
à des personnes rencontré dans les rues
de Fort-de-France pour savoir comment et
les autres voyaient le rapport de la
Martinique à l'Union européenne un
reportage réalisé par Marc François
calmo avec le montage de George Badia
j'aime m'intéresse pas trop à la
politique voilà mais l'Europe en général
vous savez quels sont nos rapports avec
l'Europe non pas vraiment là non
je suis que les chefs
pardon les agriculteurs que l'Europe
permet aux étudiants de voyager d'aller
faire des études ailleurs avec enfin
dans d'autres pays européens
je pense que au niveau de
de tout ce qui est infrastructures etc
il y a une petite part quand même
l'Europe l'Europe bon tout le monde sait
que maintenant c'est la mondialisation
donc si on a avec la mondialisation et
c'est difficile ah ouais même je regarde
chez nous
ce n'est l'impact de l'Europe puisque
c'est la mondialisation avant ça va
toucher tout le monde c'est comme le
covid l'Europe c'est quoi
la jeune les
est-ce que vous voyez un petit peu ce
que l'Europe fait en Martinique quand on
parle de fonds européens est-ce que vous
savez ce que l'Europe peut financer
genre les légumes comme ça mais après je
vois pas qu'est-ce qui peut faire au
niveau de la loi aussi c'est pas
tellement ça voilà vous vous sentez
comment tant que je ne martiniquaise de
18 ans martiniquaise française
européenne c'est quoi Martinique
voilà il ne s'agit pas d'un sondage
évidemment sont des personnes que nous
avons rencontrées dans les rues de
Fort-de-France prise au hasard qui nous
avons posé la question comme ça on
l'entend il y a une forme de
méconnaissance avec accepter une dame
qui connaît visiblement très bien
l'Europe est-ce que vous comprenez ce
que vous sentez un petit peu responsable
aussi en tant que député européen
aujourd'hui de cette forme de
méconnaissance du fait que peu de
personnes en Martinique comprennent ce
rapport entre la Martinique et l'Union
européenne vous avez tout à fait raison
et votre reportage est frappé au coin du
bon sens je félicite
la dame qui connaît manifestement
parfaitement les les programmes
européens mais vous avez tout à fait
raison alors un petit peu d'histoire
rapidement vous vous rappelez de la
chanson de Dieu Desormeaux voici le loup
bon une 992 donc vous savez très bien
comment initialement l'Europe a été
perçue pour nos territoires c'était donc
un danger et non pas un atout la
deuxième chose oui non seulement je
partage votre point de vue à savoir que
l'Europe est méconnu mais c'est aussi
les raisons pour lesquelles je suis là
aujourd'hui et nous nous sommes
rencontrés à d'autres moments dans des
lycées ou justement j'essayais de porter
la communication sur ce que l'Europe
fait alors je veux bien prendre ma part
de responsabilité là-dessus mais je
pense que l'Union européenne accorde à
la Martinique par an 100 millions
d'euros sur un programme de 7 ans et que
la CTM est un et l'instance de gestion
des fonds européens c'est un secret pour
personne et qu'il convient aussi à
chacun de faire sa part c'est-à-dire
d'expliquer et bien on finance le lycée
schel cher on finance le TCSP on finance
des infrastructures mais on finance
également des programmes pour la
jeunesse pour la culture pour la pêche
et pour l'instant c'est vrai qui me dit
un de vos d'une personne du
micro-trottoir l'Europe est aussi
compris comme un GAB un guichet et
l'Europe ce n'est pas que ça alors
justement est-ce que cette
méconnaissance relative de l'Europe ici
mais c'est pas la Martinique bien
entendu ce que vous avez les contacts
avec vos
collègues députés à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg est-ce que ça n'explique pas
en partie notre faible participation aux
élections Parlement européen qui ont
lieu tous les 5 ans nous allons
découvrir un schéma réalisé par notre
service infographie Mylène Charleville
Nelson et Sandra kutney et qui permet de
voir que la Martinique va très peu c'est
la courbe la plus bassin et la courbe
verte de 2014 à 2000 2004 par là 2019 ça
aussi notre 11 à 15 % en orange nous
avons la courbe de la participation dans
tous les outremets en français en bleu
la courbe de la France et puis la courbe
rouge c'est celle de la rencontre
merci c'est celle de la participation de
tous les pays européens voilà une
participation faible voire même très
faible pour les élections Parlement
européennes qui comme vous le dites et
col législateur donc qui fabriquent la
loi et donc il valide les programmes
d'aide aux structures aux entreprises à
l'activité et aux infrastructures vous
avez là encore tout à fait raison cela
prouve justement le désintérêt de la
population pour des élections qu'ils ne
comprennent pas que la population ne
comprend pas on ne voit pas l'intérêt
parce qu'on ne voit pas qui c'est OK
fait bah ouais qu'est-ce que tu vas
faire c'est une liste etc à cet égard je
voudrais dire que
un territoire d'outre-mer qui vote quand
même mieux que nous si vous aviez eu
c'est la Réunion regardez bon la réunion
a toujours voté quand même à plus de 40%
là-dessus nous la courbe baisse
d'élection en élections et justement ma
présence aussi est durant toute ma
législature c'est d'essayer de porter
l'information montrer un petit peu tout
l'intérêt parce que aujourd'hui il faut
se dire que les directive européenne
dans la hiérarchie des normes s'impose
sur le droit national la loi européenne
s'impose à la loi française la directive
européenne forcément l'Union Européenne
a une valeur juridique supra juridique
par rapport aux lois ordinaires du
Parlement c'est-à-dire que vous le savez
un citoyen peut porter objection d'une
loi française qui s'opposerait à une
directive européenne bon voilà ce sont
ce sont quand même des arguments
valables appartenir à la première la
puissance commerciale mondiale répétée
un peu plus souvent au martiniquais
aujourd'hui d'autant plus aujourd'hui
appartenir à cette puissance commerciale
c'est important et pourtant c'est vrai
que Oliver encore mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai parce que
je crois que il faudrait également que
les politiques locales qui bénéficient
des fonds européens en face la promotion
il faudrait aussi que l'éducation
nationale on parle davantage dans les
lycées
par rapport
US au programme
Erasmus dont on parlera sûrement
ultérieurement et par rapport aux
valeurs l'Europe ce ne s'est pas qu'un
guichet de fond c'est aussi des valeurs
je rappelle simplement que vous savez
comme vous le savez nous sommes il y a
un conflit qui s'appelle le conflit
Ukraine Russie qui est en Europe la
guerre est en Europe et vous vous
souvenez qu'il y a quelques semaines
il y a un missile qui est tombé en
Pologne
et pendant 24 heures la panique c'était
de se demander d'où il venait parce que
si c'était du côté russe cela engageait
dans une guerre les 27 pays de l'Union
européenne
il faut que nos compatriotes sachent
également que bon on est ici si nous
étions agressés par une puissance
extérieure et bien non seulement c'est
la France mais c'est aussi l'Union
européenne qui viendrait à nos côtés je
ne souhaite pas ça veut pas dire qu'il
faille depuis longtemps être mais
globalement moi je veux dire je
rencontre aussi bien en Guadeloupe en
Guyane partout je suis passé des chefs
d'entreprise qui nécessite des besoins
et un accompagnement européen donc eux
ils le savent mais les générations à
venir au niveau des politiques locales
peut-être un niveau des politiques
locales je pense qu'il y a un vrai
travail à faire et qui ne nécessite pas
de renier une quelconque identité je
suis européen je suis français et je
suis profondément martiniquais et je n'y
vois aucun
justement nous allons tout de suite nous
intéresser à la deuxième partie de
l'émission elle est consacrée à l'Europe
et la Martinique
[Musique]
la Martinique bénéficie d'un virement
800 millions d'euros de fonds européens
sur la période allant de 2021 à 2027
c'est font sont essentiels
plus exactement par la collectivité et
territoriale de Martinique qui est
l'organe de gestion de ses fonds et donc
s'ils font concerne tous les secteurs
j'allais dire de l'activité économique
sociale et culturelle
il n'y a pas que les l'Europe qui
financent s'ils font évidemment puisque
c'est toujours en collaboration avec
l'État et nos collectivités 601 millions
d'euros exactement pour le développement
économique et la cohésion sociale comme
vous disent à peu près 200 millions nous
avons également 17 millions d'euros pour
soutenir les efforts des professionnels
de la pêche et de l'agriculture on peut
estimer que c'est pas assez vous allez
nous expliquer maxorville et en fait 85
millions d'euros pour l'agriculture
c'est pour la seule Martinique bien
évidemment sachant qu'il y a 27 pays en
Europe alors une question max accent en
ville l'euro ou d'ailleurs d'où vient
tout cet argent que l'Europe redistribue
dans tous ses états membres et dans
toutes les régions dont celle de
Martinique alors avant de vous répondre
je voudrais compléter ce que vous avez
dit dans le cadre du prochain plan
pluriel des 7 ans le budget européen
pour la Martinique va encore augmenter
des fonds européens de 7%. donc je
voudrais simplement dire que les la
Martinique on va dépasser les 800
millions d'euros
pour les 7 prochaines années
les régions
ultramarines ça représente 3% de la
population de la population française et
pourtant il faut que porter à
l'attention des téléspectateurs que
20% des fonds européens alloués à la
France vont aux régions
ultra périphériques c'est-à-dire
l'outre-mer français et pourquoi c'est
parce que tout simplement ça veut dire
que
l'Union européenne la France prennent en
compte nos spécificités et nos
difficultés et notre problème de
développement donc est-ce que l'Europe
est donc aide et bien oui ça c'est clair
on ne peut pas nier que on a des fonds
et un regard j'ai envie de dire sur nos
difficultés alors pour la question
précise comme vous disiez
ultra précise d'où vient l'argent
européen l'argent bénéfice là l'argent
européen vient des sommes reversées par
chaque État de qui a 27 États et donc
tout est géré au niveau de l'Union
européenne donc chaque est à côté
à la Lituanie qui arrive de donner
autant que ce que verse la France ou
l'Allemagne est-ce que j'exagère si je
dis que le comme c'est de l'argent
public que l'Europe reçoit de
l'argentisation le budget de la France
par exemple qui est alimenté par le
budget de nos impôts et taxes que nous
tous contribuables et consomm et en
payant bien sûr ah oui oui tout à fait
mais lorsque vous regardez
une fois que c'est dans le pot commun je
suis certain que quelquefois ça dépasse
ce que nous donnons notre contribution
mais bon donc oui cet argent européen et
gérer par la Commission européenne et
donc et reversé selon au prorata de
chaque État etc selon des programmes
spécifiques
justement ils se disent souvent ici que
malheureusement nous n'utilisons pas
suffisamment les fonds européens qui
nous sont destinés comment cela est-ce
possible monsieur le député bon alors
comme l'a dit votre collègue Jean-Marc
parti nous avons une somme qui est
allouée alloué ça veut pas dire que on
vous donne de l'argent et puis
débrouiller vous il y a une somme qui
est allouée globale et une somme qui est
allouée par filière c'est à dire comme
vous l'avez dit si c'est le fait Ader
c'est-à-dire le fond développement
régional c'est le FSE c'est pour la
question de l'emploi si c'est la
question de l'agriculture c'est le poséi
si c'est interrégional etc et donc avec
des montants des sommes X ou Y
les les
usagers ça peut être aussi des
entreprises comme ça peut être aussi les
collectivités donc entre dans une de ces
filières que je viens d'indiquer à
partir de projets à partir de projets
alors pour pouvoir voilà on va être
essayer d'être pédagogique pour pouvoir
recevoir les fonds européens il faut
être un porteur de projet au niveau de
la Martinique c'est cette somme de 700
millions à peu près et gérer par la CTM
c'est à dire par la collectivité
territoriale qui a obtenu pour la
plupart des fonds une une compétence de
gestionnaire bien elle peut le partager
avec l'État parfois
c'est le cas de du FSE et puis donc tout
le monde entendu parler de ses fonds
mais d'abord il faut il y a un appel à
projet ensuite il faut des des
usagers qui vont faire des
demandes de dossier et c'est là que les
choses se corsent voilà alors elle se
corse à
deux niveaux ou trois niveaux le premier
niveau c'est le côté administratif des
dossiers comme vous le disiez c'est de
l'argent public donc cet argent public
européen répond à des critères d'une
comment dirais-je d'une sévérité ou il
faut tout doit être justifié ou les
projets doivent répondre à une action
spécifique etc donc il y a déjà un
processus j'ai envie de dire assez
rébarbatif qui nécessite une un
accompagnement pour les porteurs de
projets par exemple vous voulez monter
un projet pour aller la télé quelque
chose comme ça et bien vous allez vous
adresser selon le projet bon ben ça
répond à cela et puis vous allez
demander à la CTM ou un porteur de
projet à quelqu'un un lobbyiste ou
quelqu'un de vous aider à monter ce
projet c'est gratuit il faut payer
alors si vous pour ma part si on
s'adresse à normalement l'organisme de
gestion elle devrait pouvoir être en
capacité d'aider à accompagner les
projets ça arrive pour certains c'est
pas forcément pour tous le netteté me
pousse à dire que certains arrivent ce
il y a des lobbyistes qui se font des
spécialistes de montage de projet et
donc rémunération contre rémunération
ce qui est déjà une inégalité et bien
après je vous parlerai des difficultés
puisqu'on a un tissu économique composé
de petites voies de toutes petites
entreprises et le deuxième niveau de
blocage le deuxième niveau de blocage
c'est que l'Europe finance maximum
globalement moyenne à 75 70 ou 80% maxi
ce qui veut dire que quand vous faites
un projet il faut que vous puissiez
apporter un prêt financement de 20%. si
on a si on est sur un financement à 80
l'autre difficulté c'est que les banques
privées ne sont pas encore
les garanties bancaires
proposées par soit la CTM ou soit le
Conseil Régional de Guadeloupe n'a
aucune incidence je travaille le
parcours du combattant c'est pas si
simple nous sommes d'accord mais il y a
une partie incitative et vraiment ce qui
veut dire que si vous avez dans une à la
CTM et il y a des spécialistes qui
peuvent vous aider vous guider c'est
bien pour ça que je vous ai dit il y a
une première série de difficultés faut
être prêt maintenant
j'entends aussi le chef d'entreprise qui
me dit ouais mais moi je suis une toute
petite entreprise je n'ai pas les 20%.
et ça c'est une vraie difficulté et le
député que je suis
va rencontrer dans les mois dans les
deux mois qui viennent les grandes
banques publiques
caisse de consignation et de dépôt
banque des territoires AFD etc pour voir
avec eux comment simplifier les choses
alors avant d'arriver à l'aéroportage
illustratif sur cette question Maxence
en ville est-ce que en Martinique on est
comme dégagé plus mauvaise élève que par
exemple nos collègues de Guadeloupe de
Guyane ou de la réunion de la Réunion
ils sont spécialistes vous me le
confirmer de la consommation des fleurs
européens parce que une vraie expertise
dans le montage des dossiers en Guyane
là également ils deviennent des
spécialistes c'est ce que nous avons à
prendre exemple sur ce qui se fait
ailleurs oui mais il y a pas de fatalité
en la matière on peut avoir été je suis
l'enseignant que je suis on peut avoir
été très mauvais et se décider à vouloir
changer et à mettre les choses en place
d'autant que pour gérer par exemple ça
j'ai obtenu suite à un échange avec la
Commission européenne la semaine
dernière vous voyez c'est tout c'est
tout chaud c'est tout c'est tout frais
la Commission européenne constate
effectivement la difficulté qu'elle a à
pouvoir comment dirais-je faire mieux
connaître l'Europe et les difficultés
qui sont remontées et donc elle envisage
de pouvoir
former des consultants à Bruxelles qui
vont venir en Martinique pour former
tant sur le point de la CTM quand même
temps répondent aux questions des
usagers et leur donner une une piste oui
alors donc avec ce reportage qui
illustre à quoi servent les Européens et
comment ils se utilisaient encore une
jalosef avec son équipe tourner au
village bycé ah c'est un accélérateur de
Start pour comprendre et tout dans le
reportage qui a été réalisé avec Marc
François calmo sur mon montage de gens
je Badia et un mixage de Michel
Jean-Gilles
les grands acteurs hôpitaux ARS etc il y
avait le petit écho dog qui démarrait
très fier et ça nous a permis aussi
d'avoir du coup un financement fédéral
qui nous a beaucoup aidés pour pour
avancer et recruter développer etc un
aspect hyper important que justement les
fonds
de développer c'est le recrutement très
clairement on aboie avant on se fait un
projet on va nulle part si on n'a pas
l'équipe qui va avec et du coup avoir la
défense ça permet du coup de recruter
des équipes c'est sûr qu'il y a le côté
aussi projet il faut que les gens
croient au projet ça c'est hyper
important de savoir pourquoi on fait ce
qu'on fait parce que si on n'y croit pas
en réalité il y aura pas vraiment cet
intérêt cette volonté ce sacrifice etc
ça c'est vraiment crucial mais en même
temps il faut aussi pouvoir que les
payer les gens qui puissent être à
l'aise se nourrir avoir une voiture
enfin être confortable donc les deux
ensemble c'est sûr que ça n'a rien à
voir une bonne équipe et du coup encore
une fois d'aller plus vite d'aller plus
loin à l'époque pour la période 2014
2020 les fonds européens dans leur
ensemble étaient estimé à 800 millions
d'euros somme destinés au développement
du territoire martiniquais
précisions
de voir à financer de à bénéficier du
financement BPI la banque publique
l'investissement dans le cadre de la
French tech et la Martinique est
d'ailleurs assez bien placé alors que
sur ce sujet max en ville on le voit
c'est pas parce qu'on a un projet qu'on
est forcément sélectionné parce que
l'Europe a quand même des critères de
sélection des fiabilité assez rigoureux
tout à fait il y a c'est ce que j'ai dit
au départ vous avez un projet maintenant
il faut que vos projets puissent
répondre aux critères d'éligibilité au
niveau de l'Europe pour toutes sortes de
raisons je vous ai dit parce que c'est
de l'argent public il faut savoir
comment il va être dépensé il faut
connaître la capacité des uns et des
autres à pouvoir le mener au bout parce
qu'entre temps ce qu'on ne dit pas bon
là c'est un grand succès je m'en réjouis
mais il y a aussi des des entreprises
qui font des faillites et ce qui
explique quelquefois la non utilisation
des fonds européens parce que quand on
entend souvent pour la Martin que 100%
ou 124% sont des fonds programmés alors
il faut pas faut faire attention entre
le mot programmer et le mot réaliser a
quitter consommer et c'est là la
différence quand je dis que moins de 50
% du FSE et dépenser ici ça c'est la
note pardon oui une précision
c'est-à-dire
européen qui est destiné
l'emploi c'est bien ça aujourd'hui alors
le chiffre que j'ai récupéré juste avant
de venir à l'émission Bon c'est celui
qui est sur le site de la Commission
européenne donc on va pas dire que
maxorville dit n'importe quoi c'est
moins de la moitié du budget du Fond
Social Européen qui est dépensé en
Martinique selon les dernières chips
seulement 23 millions sur 70 millions
prévus ont été certifiés par la CTM 34%
c'est dû à quoi selon moi un manque de
volonté politique
je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui qui fait
des procès d'intention mais je veux dire
encore une fois je crois qu'il y a une
question de management d'ingénierie et
parfois peut-être on peut se tromper et
puis peut-être
durant durant le dispositif il y a des
des choses qui avaient été programmées
et qui se révèle ne pas pouvoir se tenir
vous pouvez avoir des entreprises qui au
cours de cette attente on fait faillite
par exemple donc il y a plein de de
possibilités et encore une fois je vous
dis il y a un certain nombre
d'ingénierie je pose un autre problème
la région Grand Est de l'Hexagone qui
est celle qui a consommé le plus de
fonds européens je ne vais pas comparer
ce qui est incomparable à la région
Grand Est combien de millions
d'habitants etc mais le service des
affaires européennes
c'est 270 personnes
270 la Guyane j'en reviens c'est 70
personnes la Guadeloupe c'est une
centaine de personnes je ne sais pas il
faudra poser la question
mais ce que je veux dire là-dessus je le
chiffre que j'ai entendu de la
conseillère exécutif c'était il y a un
an c'était qu'à peu près elle va traiter
plus de 3000 dossiers combien de
personnes pour traiter ces dossiers en
Martinique monsieur le député vous
devriez le savoir en tant que débuter
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que je
crois encore une fois que l'Europe est
nécessaire pour le développement de la
Martinique je crois que aujourd'hui
et j'ai des divergences parfois avec le
président de la CTM l'avenir se passe
aujourd'hui à Bruxelles et à Paris pour
le développement il faut des experts il
faut recruter des experts il faut mettre
les moyens je pense qu'il faut
effectivement mettre les moyens il faut
qu'on ait les moyens de notre ambition
pour le développement il faut une
meilleure communication vous entendu sur
le micro-trottoir si on sait pas ce
qu'on cherche on sait pas ce qu'on
trouve il y a beaucoup de de
martiniquais qui ont des projets qui ont
du talent et on parlera tout à l'heure
de de l'Europe des talents et ce qu'on
veut faire aussi en Martinique je crois
qu'il faut du monde pour accompagner les
porteurs de projets qui ne savent
peut-être pas tout donc je ne dis pas
qu'il y a de la mauvaise volonté ce
n'est pas ce que je dis je dis
simplement que il faut mettre le paquet
pour que l'argent de l'Europe
qui est disponible pour les
martiniquaise pas pour moi c'est pas
pour la CTM pour les Martiniquais il
faut que cet argent ne repartent pas et
que cet argent soit utilisé alors
j'entends moins en tant que rodé
tout de suite en discuter dans la
troisième partie de l'émission La
Martinique dans l'Europe comment ça se
passe c'est la troisième partie
[Musique]
alors on entend il faut quand même des
relations enfin bon il faut aussi des
moyens des experts en tout cas c'est un
vrai travail en tout cas que de mener à
terme ces fonds européens on voudrait
savoir justement le président du conseil
exécutif de la CTM à travers l'Europe il
souhaite viser un plan de relance verte
c'est à dire
parce que là c'est c'est une volonté
mais alors je vais vous dire le député
européen que je suis même si je suis
martiniquais vous m'autoriserez à devoir
de réserve en tant que député européen
mon rôle c'est d'accompagner les
politiques mises en place par le
président de la CTM par le président de
le Conseil Régional de la Guadeloupe et
tous les exécutifs c'est peut-être aussi
une c'est un projet la relance verte
avec l'autonomie alimentaire notamment
je suis en Europe peut accompagner
l'Europe accompagne déjà il y a la
question déposée bon le poséiste et
l'alternative de la pacte de la
politique agricole en France bon
j'entends et je sais les les
difficultés les remises en cause de
l'attribution du poséi pour certaines
filières la diversification
qui disent que les planteurs de bananes
de Martinique reçoivent trop d'argent
par rapport aux autres filières et qu'il
faut rééquilibrer la répartition des
fonds publics européen pour mieux
soutenir les cultures maraîchères
vivrières et de levage vous êtes
d'accord avec ça
je répète encore une fois mon temps que
député européen moi je je vote le poser
je me bats pour avoir un poséidropéen un
fonds européen le plus
généreux possible ça c'est ma tâche
c'est ma mission
les politiques locales dans les
différents territoires sont ceux que
vous dites j'entends je ne suis
absolument pas sourd il y a deux
semaines j'ai accompagné le ministre
caraco et nous étions sur des
exploitations et j'entendais donc
effectivement aussi bien les
récriminations des agriculteurs et des
planteurs de bananes etc moi je vais
redire ce que j'ai dit il y a encore
deux semaines j'ai dit moi député
européen et martiniquais ultramarin je
veux le meilleur pour tout le monde mais
je ne veux pas déshabiller monsieur
comment dirais-je monsieur c'est banane
monsieur lui-même au profit de manen de
Madame hôtel je vais militer pour ma
part pour une augmentation du poséi pour
la diversification en faveur
d'adversification notamment au travers
d'une augmentation du sium c'est-à-dire
du montant alloué par le ministère de
l'Agriculture d'accord pourquoi comme je
vous l'ai dit je ne veux pas créer de
division entre martiniquais parce que
j'entendais que vous êtes allé vous même
sur le terrain vous entendez aussi les
récriminations des planteurs de bananes
qu'on leur dit qu'on va on va aller
jouer dans leur gamelle comme il disait
mais la deuxième chose
la banane et le rhum sont des produits
d'exportation qui sont en concurrence
avec la banane des dollars qui
qui a suscité la banane antillaise un
certain nombre de d'adaptations de
transformation pour être compétitive il
y a la banane africaine aussi et donc ce
produit là est un produit j'ai envie de
dire labellisé c'est comme le rhum donc
nos productions doivent être protégées
et la diversification doit être
encouragée voilà
c'est très clair
il ne nous reste pas beaucoup de temps
donc nous avons vu en début d'émission
avec l'Union européenne reste quand même
assez méconnu mais pas vraiment pour
certains élèves de Seconde notamment au
lycée de Bellevue ils ont choisi
l'option Europe on les écoute
c'est vraiment une richesse ça apporte
quelque chose on est plus ouvert et
aussi franchement trouver des cultures
différentes
à prendre de nouvelles choses voir
comment ça se passe dans d'autres pays
c'est vraiment intéressant
et aussi rencontrer plein de gens parce
que que ce soit avec
Erasmus quand on part ou quand ils
viennent quand on fait des modélisations
des Nations unies ou juste quand on
rencontre des gens qui reviennent
d'autres horizons c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir comment comment ils
vivent comment ils voient le monde et
l'Europe offre beaucoup de possibilités
de voyage mais aussi de financement
pas forcément pour
financement pour un peu tout donc nous
les jeunes mais aussi pour
fonder une association ou une entreprise
avoir des fonds pour pouvoir avancer
donc oui ça pas mal d'avantages c'est
récemment j'ai intégré une association
qui traite de l'Europe aussi donc ça m'a
un peu on m'a parlé de l'Europe et j'ai
compris certaines choses que j'avais
jamais vu comme quoi par exemple
beaucoup de choses en Martinique était
financées par l'Europe et ça je savais
pas même récemment nous a donné des
ordinateurs que je savais pas que
c'était l'Europe et je pensais que
c'était juste un Martinique toute seule
voilà voilà le reportage donc réalisé
par vos Corinne Jean Joseph avec Georges
Badia au montagne sur des images
d'Olivier Nicolas duduclos il y a de
quoi être optimisme je vous ai vu
sourire pendant cette diffusion oui
parce qu'effectivement j'ai reconnu
quelques visages de jeunes lycéens que
j'avais rencontré alors à l'occasion de
la Journée européenne de la jeunesse et
dans laquelle j'avais évoqué avec eux
l'Europe et tous les programmes qui leur
étaient offerts donc je suis heureux de
voir que ça a sensibilisé quand même ces
jeux de martiniquais sur l'intérêt de
l'Europe donc une autre une autre
initiative assez récente de l'Union
européenne vient d'être lancée deux mots
rapidement à la fin de l'émission
consiste à contrer la fuite des cerveaux
et donc un rayer le décret démographique
ce qui nous concerne particulièrement en
Guadeloupe et en Martinique et bien oui
c'est une communication européenne qui
date de la semaine dernière qui n'a pas
un fond de financement
établi mais qui va bénéficier de tous
les programmes européens annexes etc
l'idée c'est simple nous avons une
baisse démographique constatée par tous
il y a pas de discussion là-dessus et
l'Union européenne on a si on l'a
regardé comme ça de loin on peut dire
mais elle s'en fiche complètement pas du
tout l'Union européenne souhaite qu'on
conserve nos talents souhaite qu'on
empêche la fuite de nos cerveaux et en
conséquence par l'intermédiaire
d'Erasmus plus veut permettre de à nos
jeunes de partir et de revenir et de
promouvoir
des activités qui leur sont chères même
et surtout de promouvoir notre propre
identité l'Union européenne ce n'est pas
on ne se noie pas dans l'universel au
contraire on s'enrichit de nos
diversités de ce qu'on est donc le plus
pour ses enfants de partir pour ses
enfants parce que globalement c'est
quand cette jeunesse va revenir va
identifier par exemple je veux
travailler dans le numérique dans la
fibre dans la cosmétique etc et j'ai
envie de réaliser ça sur mon territoire
et bien l'Union européenne favorise se
maintient c'est ce qu'on appelle enrayer
la fuite des cerveaux et donc il y a
plusieurs pour que nous ayons là aussi
si peu d'élèves qui partent et
bénéficient qui du programme RS je pense
encore une fois je l'ai dit je crois que
nous devrions être aidé plus puissamment
tant par les autorités de gestion là CTM
que par l'Éducation nationale qui fait
un petit peu de l'Europe des valeurs
oubliées et le député européen que je
suis va rencontrer le prochainement le
ministre la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur parce que j'ai la volonté de
labelliser des lycées européens ça ne
veut pas dire uniquement être biling
trilingue ça veut dire aussi faire
connaître les valeurs européennes
d'humanisme etc
un dernier mot également puisque l'Union
européenne aussi bien ça s'occupe de des
artistes là aussi et visiblement ils ne
sont pas au courant de de certaines
choses
une faille mais qui incombe peut-être
aux autorités de gestion c'est à dire un
manque d'information dans le cadre de
d'un programme qui s'appelle horizon
Europe avec avec un paragraphe qui
s'appelle culture mauve Europe qui a été
lancé fin début novembre et qui
consistait à permettre à nos artistes de
pouvoir voyager se confronter avec
d'autres artistes de par exemple je
pense à la yole et bien si vous allez au
Pays Basque il y a d'autres manières de
faire du nautisme etc et tout se
confronter que ça soit sur le plan
musical sur le plan artistique sur le
plan peinture etc et c'était financé par
l'Union européenne dans le cadre de ce
programme malheureusement ce programme
expire mi-février donc c'est pour moi
une perte de chance et je ne souhaite
plus que ça se reproduise et c'est pour
ça que je dis que à partir de ce soir
j'annonce un scoop sur le site
maxorville.eu c'est mon site
parlementaire vous y trouverez tous les
programmes de l'Union européenne les
objectifs les procédures et ceci pour
tous les territoires
ultramains
comme Maxence en ville la voix de
l'outre-mer exactement alors une
dernière question max en ville il y a
toujours cette nécessité de demander des
permissions de dérogations vu du point
de vue de région ultra périphériques de
l'autre côté en français vous voulez que
ça c'est ce qu'on soit pleinement
intégré au campus législatif juridique
de l'Europe une fois contre non je
souhaite que l'Union européenne ne parle
moins européen prennent en compte les 7
euros députés et donc les spécificités
des Outre-mer suite à la conférence des
rupes des régions ultra périphériques
qui s'étonnent à Bruxelles sous la
présidence de Serge les chimie il a été
admis par toute l'assemblée que
l'article 349 du traité de Lisbonne qui
signale que l'Union européenne doit
tenir compte des spécificités des autres
mères avaient une portée en vérité très
faible puisque chaque décision du
Parlement ou de la commission nous
étions obligés de déposer des
amendements ou des dérogations je
souhaite que ça cesse et que nous
puissions à l'occasion une rencontre que
je vais proposer à tous les
parlementaires nationaux des Outre-mer
eurodéputés et président des exécutifs
dans un séminaire que j'appelle objectif
méthode définir dans quel domaine par
exemple cet article 349 va s'appliquer
énergie environnement éducation
transport de façon à échapper au coup
près chaque fois demander une dérogation
très bien monsieur le député européen
maxorville merci beaucoup